does 24 gigabytes supercharge the m2
chip that is in the new m2 macbook air
and macbook pro well nobody has actually
tested it side by side so today we will
find out once and for all with real
world productivity apps and tests now
you previously had to jump up to 32
gigabytes but now if you're already
getting the 16 gigabyte which has a huge
speed improvement over the 8 gig model
you only have to spend 200 more to jump
up to the
gigabyte and will the extra ram and the
different bandwidths help a lot let's
take a look now right out of the gate we
are using close to 5 gigabytes of ram
with nothing open other than our
creative cloud uh application that's
small in the background so that's why
some people don't want to get the eight
gig model already because you dump into
swap like we showed before by just even
opening up web browsing and a lot of
people want to avoid swap so they can
extend their ssd life and maybe the 24
gig model is going to really help with
that and even if we open up pro
applications it will stay out from using
the ssd now the first thing i'm going to
do is open up some web browsing tabs
because if you're using a system like
this and you're upgrading the ram you're
definitely going to be having some stuff
open honestly i think everybody does now
i only opened up five tabs i have my
email my google drive loaded up a
youtube video playing in the background
like i often do either music or podcast
or something and then i have um ign
opened up right here which does have a
lot of media and then the verge which
does have some auto playing ads in the
background that refresh just like a lot
of websites do so this is a pretty easy
scenario now i want to get some baseline
performance numbers uh when we just have
one application open just a few web
browsing tabs i'll start out with
speedometer 2.0 which is going to test
the snappiness for web-based
applications and just general browsing
it looks like the performance is very
similar here with chrome with just that
open and we'll check back later once we
have more things going now like many
apps lightroom classic can now use the
gpu to accelerate your photo editing and
when you're using that it's sharing the
same ram with the cpu because it's all
in one chip and we saw that the 8 gig
model was a lot slower than the 16 gig
model even when we had nothing open but
lightroom so let's see if 24 gigs can
make it faster now as far as editing the
files switching between them and these
here have all the effects already
pre-added so it has to render all of
that on the fly there is really no
difference now let's go ahead and hit
export i'm going to start my timer and
we'll see if we notice any gains or
differences now opening up the activity
monitor here wow even now we have swap
used on both of these that is crazy i
wonder if it's using that for maybe
faster performance we have 4.6 gigs of
swap on the 16 gig model and 2.4 on the
24 gig now maybe if we didn't have
google drive open or the youtube video
then maybe it would be a little bit
better but mac os doesn't shy away from
using swap even on my mac pro that has
192 gigabytes of ram it will still use
swap even though it's not all maxed out
bam we are done
and we actually had a difference the 16
gig model finished in a minute and 18
seconds which was already super fast but
the 24 gig did it in a minute and eight
seconds so that's a difference of over
10 percent which is you know pretty
impressive if you're already spending a
lot of money on the system now keep in
mind that if you're gonna be exporting a
lot of images say 300 for portrait
shooters family shooters or a thousand
or more for wedding photographers that
will add up and now let's test out xcode
we are compiling our project right now
and as you see the memory pressure and
the swap used went down dramatically
once we closed lightroom and it's very
low right now and honestly it's
interesting that it's actually there
because our memory used is very low
we're only using about nine gigs out of
16 or 24 and mac os is still wanting to
use a tiny bit of swap all right we are
done and the export time was basically
identical
119 seconds on each one so we're not
seeing a difference i think our previous
test even when we loaded stuff up we saw
barely any variance for xcode the same
thing goes for blender where most of our
projects they would be pretty much
identical in rendering and it didn't
really max out the memory now there are
some projects that will use a ton of
memory and if you work on those you'll
know it so let's see what the difference
is all right very interesting now last
time the 8 gig model took 37 seconds
compared to 6.6 for the 16. this time
this also got the same exact time here
but the 24 gig just got
6.69 slightly longer basically the same
so we're not seeing any difference now
this render right here we're using
cycles because it's faster and it's over
a six gigabyte
image that is rendered here so there's a
lot of data but i guess that's not
enough to make a difference so let's
make this a little bit tougher and now
it looks like we are running into swap
on the 16 gig model but not any more
than we had before in the 24 gig and
look at that we have
22.9 seconds basically 23 for the 16 and
19.13
for the 24. that's still not a very big
difference and this project right here
this render is over 15 gigs in size so
personally i would say for blender it's
not worth spending that extra 200 bucks
and now let's test video editing with
final cut pro now for simple 4k
compressed footage even with effects
there is really no difference even with
the 8 gig model it did great because of
the media engines and how little ram it
actually uses now when it comes to
tougher footage like this prores raw and
we're encoding to prores those new
encoders in the m2 chip definitely need
some extra ram especially if you are
gonna be multitasking let's go ahead and
export this and i do have some color
corrections applied a lot and look at
that we are seeing no difference
whatsoever they're exporting exactly the
same on both opening up the activity
monitor we did get a boost in memory
pressure on both but only the 16 gig
added some swap compared to before but
the times are practically identical in
fact the 16 gig model took a minute and
37 seconds compared to a minute and 39
seconds for the 24 gig now i'm gonna run
that one more time but i want to test
out multitasking performance usually
when i'm rendering video and this is
just a short project
i will do some multitasking i'll go do
some email
some other things so let's see if we
have any difference in responsiveness
first off let's go ahead and open up
google drive bam instant on both
open up youtube instant on both no
difference
we have our ign we have the verge
we are having no issues whatsoever here
let's run speedometer as far as if
you're opening up maybe some google
docs or other web-based services both
are just flying through this and keep in
mind we are still exporting here at the
same exact time here we go it did slow
down because we're exporting but the
results are the same actually the 16 gig
did a little bit better uh this is what
i love about mac os that you could still
do fast responsive tasks while you're
multitasking bam both of these got done
now this time around they did take a
little bit longer because we were
opening up things in the background and
this really hammers the cpu and the gpu
and our 16 gig model took a minute and
40 seconds compared to a minute 39 on
the 24 gig so very good results and the
16 gig is holding up great and now let's
make it more difficult i'm going to
start out by opening up more web
browsing tabs i have 15 opened up right
here in chrome including a second email
some other websites i'm gonna go ahead
and open up safari here where i have
five additional tabs opened up here with
a google sheets as well a lot of you
guys said that you have 20 or 30 tabs
open so here is 20 and it's interesting
that both these are still using a little
bit of swap but our 24 gig is using a
lot more actual memory i have final cut
still opened up here in the background
with a small project and it's not taking
up that much ram and i'll go ahead and
open up photoshop and i have this open
often with images while i do video
editing and multitasking and it looks
like both of them opened it up at the
same time so there's no extra benefit
let's go ahead and drag in these nine
images here and now let's create an hdr
that was practically identical taking 25
seconds whereas before the a gig would
definitely slow down let's go ahead and
open up lightroom classic once again and
let's export these and see if we get any
slowdowns
now as this is starting to export let me
open up our activity monitor wow both of
these are using a lot of swap we have 13
gigs over here and 11 gigs over here so
only a difference of 2 gigabytes even
though we went from 16 to 24. and we
have a difference of only 7 seconds 1
minute and 11 compared to 1 minute and
18.
so that is very impressive for the 16
gig model so if you're wondering if the
16 will slow down with a lot of swap it
doesn't really with all of that open
this video file is playing back
perfectly smoothly without any
issues still even though the ram is hit
pretty hard and exporting this they are
both chugging along at practically the
same speed
in fact
for a second there the 16 gigabyte was
ahead now as this is going let's go
ahead and open up google chrome once
again where we have 15 tabs open and
let's see if we see any kind of
difference let's open up the verge at
the same time
all right there you go you guys saw
that uh it opened up slower meaning it's
in swap here on the 16 gig the next tab
now the 24 gig opened up slower let's
open electric
all right slightly ahead on the 24 gig
the same here
how about we open up our google drive
which does take a lot of memory
a little bit faster on the 24 gig what
about our youtube video
practically the same both are still
playing ign here which has a lot open
there's actually a video playing in the
background slightly faster than the 24
but nothing like the difference we saw
with the 8 gig model and as you guys saw
there both of those exported at the same
time a minute and 47 seconds so both
slow down a little bit but the
performance is practically the same
while we're rendering maxing everything
out and using a lot of swap i have to
say i am very impressed with the 16 gig
model
how close it's keeping up and the fact
that the 24 gig isn't really doing much
of a difference that's kind of sad when
you're spending the extra money now we
have to throw some kind of a torture
test at it i don't think this is
realistic uh but everything else so far
has been great i'm gonna go ahead and
hit share we're gonna hit export file
once again let's hit save here i'm gonna
start my timer and i'm gonna go ahead
and open up lightroom classic now the
first i'm gonna do is just switch
between these images
okay
there you go you guys can see
actually now it's about the same
now the 16 gig was faster so they're
kind of trading blows here so they're
acting practically the same sometimes
one is faster sometimes the others
faster we're slowing down a bit because
that is a tough export and let's go
ahead and run this at the same time so
now we're exporting that prores raw to
prores file in
final cut and at the same time exporting
photos as well while having 20 tabs open
and using a ton of swap now it does feel
like the 24 gig is a little bit more
responsive when i'm opening this stuff
up but we're not using that much more
swap on the 16 gig compared to the 24.
now you see the 24 gig actually finished
the export
uh really quickly i mean we're talking
about a minute and 10 seconds and now
lightroom is starting to actually work
fast because our export is finished
whereas here lightroom is literally
locking up it's not doing much and let's
open up final cut oh there you go that
one got finished that took a minute and
50 seconds compared to a minute and 10
while we're exporting at the same time
and now it's starting to take off here
so it's almost like the 16 gig model
waited for that before lightroom took
off our lightroom export is done on the
24 gigabyte and now on the 16 gigabyte
so the 16 gig took three minutes and 50
seconds to export these 50 images of
course it waited for
a final cut to be done whereas this one
it started doing lightroom right away
but very slowly and that took two
minutes and 45 seconds so still not a
massive difference and of course who
would be doing both of those exports at
the same time and as you guys saw when
we were exporting and actually using
lightroom the performance was very
similar so what is the verdict well i
have to say that 24 gigs did not help
much at all and this is on the m2
macbook pro which does have fans if
you're using the m2 macbook air that
will also start throttling if you're
trying to do stuff like this two
programs at once and then so the ram
difference will be smaller just because
you are throttling so overall for most
people unless you're doing something
like crazy like this you're not really
gonna notice much of a difference and i
don't think it's really worth spending
that extra money unless you know
specifically that for your task you need
a ton of ram and in that case you're
probably not even watching this video
because you know you need it but for
most people even if you're doing stuff
like this where we have a ton of stuff
opened multiple pro applications ton of
web browsing tabs the difference was a
lot smaller than i personally expected
so if you're buying an m2 chip i don't
think it is worth that extra cash now on
the m1 pro or m1 max we've done videos
on those where we push them even harder
and we start to see some more
differences uh but here my
recommendation would be stick to that 16
gigs of ram and spend that 200 on
something else like maybe upgrading the
storage or maybe buying an accessory or
just saving it so there you guys go if
you want to see another great video
check out one of those right over there
click that circle above to subscribe
thank you for watching it's been max
with max tech and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]